[Musique]
en grèce d'emprunter r c'est une
association
qui est créé sous l'impulsion des
vêtements des élèves gustavo cours et on
collecte beaucoup de matériel scolaire
que ça soit informatique s'asseoir
immobiliers ou autres ou full tilt
scolaire donc du coup pour l'envoyer
dans les écoles sénégalais pour équiper
des établissements
on a prévu comment dire ceux
de présenter comment traiter revendre
les plats africaine on a organisé pour
pouvoir connecter différents pour que
nous puissions envoyer un conteneur
[Musique]
à midi on rentre vraiment une
installation en fait nous allons montrer
tout ce qu on avait fait comme intéresse
depuis le premier contrat jusqu'à
actuellement ça a dit aussi qu'il
parlait aussi comment intéresser les
difficultés qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui
le versus you des contrats sans
frontières monté ça et nous allons
comment elle va faire une exposition
longue du coup qui va tourner en boucle
[Musique]